Narrator: Why study
alone, when you can study
with a bunch of strangers
from all over the world?
This is gongbang, which translates
to "study broadcast" in Korean.
In Japan, it's known as benkyou douga,
and in the US and other
parts of the world,
it's simply called "study with me."
It's a type of video in which
people prepare for an exam
on camera, while other people
watch and study as well.
This might not sound like
riveting entertainment,
but these videos are racking up
millions of views on YouTube.
So why are they so popular?
And is this just the
latest example of lazy
content creation, or is there
something more going on here?
Narrator: This YouTuber goes
by the name "The Man Sitting Next to Me."
He prefers to remain anonymous.
He lives in Korea and is
studying to be a tax accountant.
He livestreams himself
studying for hours at a time
and has over 20 thousand
subscribers on his channel.
His videos show him
simply sitting at a desk
taking notes or looking at a book.
Jamie Lee: You're studying
for a long time whether it's
for high school, college,
or a professional degree.
It can be really lonely,
and it's always helpful
to have sort of a study buddy.
Narrator: This is Jamie.
She lives in New York and runs
a YouTube channel called
"The Strive to Fit."
She started her channel when she was
in medical school and continues
to film herself studying
while in residency.
Unlike The Man Sitting Next to Me,
Jamie's "study with me"
videos are prerecorded.
Her videos range from around 20 minutes
to two-and-a-half hours in length,
and some have over two million views.
She offers videos with music and some
with the natural sounds of the pencil
on paper as a sort of ASMR.
Jamie: I try to cater to
different types of audiences.
It'll just be kind of the
natural sound of like,
pen and paper or book
sounds and things like that.
Narrator: With a quick YouTube search,
you can find all sorts of different people
and types of study videos to choose from.
This study video trend
is a lot like mukbang,
which has become more
popular in recent years.
It involves people eating food,
often a whole lot of it, on camera.
Looking at what's on YouTube these days,
like ASMR, mukbang, and reaction videos,
it would seem like you don't need
a whole lot of special
skills to be a success.
But gongbang serves a real
purpose, helping people focus.
Or at least that's what
the content creator
and the fans are saying.
While it may seem
distracting to watch YouTube
while doing your work,
they say it actually
is a helpful way to avoid distractions.
Narrator: And based on
some of the comments,
this method seems to be working.
"I'm an engineering student,
a week ago I wasn't motivated
at all, then I found your channel.
Thank you for saving me."
"I feel more concentrated
on my exam preparation.
Thank you Jamie for your video.
It's actually very nice and helpful."
Jamie: It really helps them
focus, because every time
they're tempted to do
something on their phone
or go somewhere on their website,
they kinda look up and see
that I'm still studying
on the screen, so it
kind of motivates them
to keep studying and stay focused
on what they're supposed to be doing.
Narrator: And while they do
make money off the videos
with YouTube ads, they say viral fame
and fortune isn't why they're doing it.
Keep in mind, these YouTubers are studying
for careers outside of YouTube,
like tax accountants and doctors.
They say they're only using YouTube
as a means to an end, that isn't becoming
the next Logan Paul or Jenna Marbles.
The Man Sitting Next to Me says
he even uses the money that he earns
to give back to his community,
charities, and nursing homes.
You can find him on
his channel interacting
with his viewers, giving out gift cards
for things like coffee
and books to help study.
Narrator: His followers will often stick
with him until they complete their exam
and share his channel with friends.
Narrator: But what happens
when the tests are over
for these YouTubers?
What can their followers expect?
Both Jamie and The Man Sitting Next to Me
say they plan to keep filming themselves
but perhaps with different
content related to their careers.
Narrator: No matter why you
watch or when you watch,
it all comes down to one thing:
making sure you do the
work and pass that test.